I don't think there is a single force as
a biologist I would have to begin with
the force of evolution clearly I believe
in evolution I believe in in the theory
of natural selection i think it's had an
enormous impact on who we are as a
species and where we are today i believe
in the power of technology i think
particularly if you look at the history
of human endeavor you could write that
history based on the kinds of
technological advances you know from the
Bronze Age on the first time someone
picked up a stick and realized it could
be a tool to what is happening today in
with the internet for example I think
that has been a tremendous tremendous
force that has affected the way we have
developed as species I think the other
would be the move away from subsistence
to creating excess which is another way
of saying the ability to move from
living hand-to-mouth to find the leak
creating wealth and what wealth allowed
individuals to do both in terms of
creating a greater comfort in the way we
live but I think also in allowing us the
leisure time that allows us as humans to
create art for example the great force
in higher education in the United States
has been has really been several things
actually now that I think about it the
first I think was the commitment really
from the very beginning of this country
to free public education that I think
was a revolutionary idea in some
respects and I think it is one that has
served the country very well in
until relatively recent times and I
think if I have one concern about how
that is now playing out today in 2007 I
worry about the enormous difference in
the quality of the very best and the
very worst of our public schools in this
country the gap between what happens in
Princeton High School and what happens
in the high schools in Trenton which are
just 20 miles away our night and day and
I worry about the degree to which are
striving for free public education has
really been diminished in this country I
think the same thing could be true about
the great state universities they were
created so that every individual capable
of doing work at the university level
would have an opportunity to go to
college as those state colleges and
universities are being financially
squeezed by their state legislatures
they have only one choice and that is to
raise tuition and as they raise tuition
those state colleges and universities
become less and less accessible to those
who are in the bottom of the income
bracket